so good morning everyone my name is mike
powell i'm an active duty US Army
officer I work at enscombe the US Army
Intelligence and Security Command on
Fort Belvoir and while my material is
coming up
you probably think there might not be
that many things that we share in common
I disagree
you probably use our for work so do I
you probably use it for a side project
or hobby so if I a good day for you
might be several hours of uninterrupted
coding and no meetings same here but
where we differ is that I do all my
coding and combat boots in camouflage in
a cubicle in an office building but I
don't really mind because if if people
can't see you they can't bother you so
when Jared talked to me about presenting
here not another thing about difference
between you means I can't put my hands
in my pockets because you don't do that
in military uniforms crazy stuff right
so when Jared talked to me about
presenting here I thought yeah sure
sounds great I asked my boss he's like
yeah absolutely and then I asked the
people that control what you say in
public and realize it was gonna be
pretty hard to give an hour talk without
talking about my work about the projects
I'm working on the data I use the
methods I use because as I said I work
in an intelligence organization and
they're kind of protective of those
things there we go
the other thing I noticed and I might
take this back to my organization is in
our ability to look cool and camouflage
we've made it impossible to read from a
distance
anything on the title slide so what I
want to talk to you about is how we're
using our in our studio really to
democratize data science to bring it
down to our analysts and get them doing
all sorts of things that they weren't
doing before alright next slide please
so the other thing I did was I think and
I'm gonna be all sneaky and I'm gonna
save my PowerPoint slides as a PDF where
they're uneditable and
are locked so that nothing could be
manipulated and misrepresent me later on
and of course I did in such a fashion
that the computer that doesn't have
Adobe Acrobat on it can't pull up my PDF
so you're looking to see it through a
web browser I think it'll work okay so
the things I want to talk about a little
bit how we're we're involving our in our
studio the whole ecosystem there to
incorporate data analysis and in every
aspect of what we do and like any other
organization the our me and my
organization INSCOM wants to leverage
data in new and powerful ways we need
people to do that we need skills through
that I'm gonna try to explain a few of
those today so we'll kind of walk
through a little bit about how we're
using data a little bit how we're trying
to increase the the data literacy of our
analysts a little bit how we're trying
to turn some tedious manual processes
into automated repeatable reproducible
workflows some of the questions we're
trying to get after that really just
weren't possible before and then finally
how we're trying to leverage shiney to
to put app development in the hands of
the analyst who's got a little bit of
know-how and a good idea all right next
slide please
Oh everybody every organization has some
diagram like this this is how we do
things right so this is the US Army
intelligence process and I would say it
mirrors many of the data science
pipelines or workflows that maybe you've
seen I'll start in the top right corner
assuming we've got a well-formed
question and that's a big assumption
right most of the time I think the
people that come to me with it with data
science dreams are thinking that data
science is going to give them the
question that we're then going to answer
for them oh we really like you to come
with a good question and if not we'll
help you refine it scope it to something
we can do in our lifetimes it may
involve some collection a little bit of
cleaning some processing we'll throw a
few analytic techniques at it and at the
end of the day hopefully we've got
something that is worth packaging up the
results of methodology something that we
want to share and maybe use again and
I'll point out that
I caution you from adopting this model
for your own organization because as you
see it goes on forever which I think you
can interpret two ways either well
that's good they're always they're
always trying to improve that's Noble or
you know who cares if we get it right
this time we're just going to do it
again alright next slide please
there we go okay
so I'd like to introduce the first
analogy that you may or may not keep up
with as we go through and that is I
walked out my front door this morning
and my yards fall leaves it wasn't
yesterday but it is today
so how do I deal with that I think I've
got a few options the first is I grab a
rake and I pick them up the second is I
get with my neighbors and use that time
I could have been raking to come up with
some grand neighborhood plan and we're
gonna come up with something that maybe
by next fall will be effective at taking
care of our leaf problem or maybe I Bank
on Fairfax County saying all our
neighborhoods have leaf problems we
should try to solve this problem for
everybody and that's going to take ten
years and ton of money and never happen
so none of those are necessarily like
bad ideas but only one of them really
takes care of my leaf problem today and
that's me doing something about it
so in our adventure or endeavor here to
incorporate data science into what we do
in our intelligence community we need
the long-term plans we need the
short-term plans but somebody's got to
do stuff today and that's what so I'm
going to talk to you a little bit about
today I think it's really important that
we take the analysts we have with the
resources we have to solve the problems
we have today one of the things we did
to get after this in the open source
intelligence community was to create a
data science course so we call it a data
science course but really it's more like
data science counseling people come in
they tell us about their problem so we
give them some coping techniques like
deep IR ggplot and and hopefully
everybody leaves a little bit a little
bit happier and better able to tackle
their job
all right next slide please
okay so the Army is a pretty old
organization 243 years old in fact and
as I've made the rounds in my
organization I've encountered a few
Excel spreadsheets that I think are
almost that old and what's tough about
the Excel spreadsheets is you know
you've got some analysts who's sitting
there for hours every day or hours every
week and they're you know copying and
pasting and filtering and joining and
splitting and merging whatever they're
doing maybe you just want to automate
that stuff for them because it's so
painful to watch a guy do that and then
you run in to the mystery VBA script
that like it's critical
our section depends on this but nobody
knows how it works and we'll never know
because the guy who wrote it
password-protected that spreadsheet like
ten years ago and then he retired so
you're you're out of line so when you
find this guy who's got the spreadsheet
job and you know you say hey let me let
me take that eight hours and turn it
into eight seconds for you it's really
interesting to see the transition that
happens both in the scope of what
they're willing to consider as a
potential question to answer
like maybe we don't just have to look at
a week's worth of data because it takes
a day to do that maybe we can look at
months or maybe we can look at years but
then they start getting needy right
because it takes maybe it's minutes to
code that does a five-year analysis and
I'm like you know you're doing a hundred
times more in an hour than you used to
do in a week like lay off me and
sometimes it sometimes it takes a minute
for for complicated things to happen but
I like to see how when you give somebody
their time back that's how we always try
to start is like let me give you your
time back so that you can think of
something better to do instead of
juggling spreadsheets on Monday maybe
you just get to think for a little bit
and maybe you get to do something a
little more worthy of human thought next
slide please
okay so in a zero diversity focus group
of the three people in my office one of
them did not recognize the left hand
side of this as my attempt to build a
Plinko board you all know what Plinko is
okay so if you don't google Plinko the
price is right and you'll you'll learn
what Plinko is all about and you'll see
why I put that up here in a minute
so manual processes are prone to error
or at least variation I think back to
some of my grad school work and I pity
anybody that followed me and was
supposed to like follow you know falling
on that project and take it to the next
level because some of that work I mean I
knew it was good at the time I knew how
the scripts worked I knew what order to
run them in I knew what assumptions I
was making but the critical shortcoming
and all that is that it required me and
if I'm not there then the whole thing
falls apart well I think anybody if you
tried to recreate some of my old figures
or something you might as well try
playing Plinko to rebuild what I had
built you just go through this random
sequence of Lu maybe you did
cross-validation maybe he removed some
outliers I don't know and I think that's
garbage right so life with our markdown
is a different thing altogether
I can capture everything from how I
acquired the data what I did to clean it
any steps I took along the way I'm
capturing it and explaining it as I go
and so this is a skill that I think has
been critical to teach our analysts like
I should be able to run a back trace on
any conclusion you draw all the way to
the start what day did you use what did
you do to that data where'd it come from
what assumptions are you making things
that seem reasonable to ask but all that
is lost when you've got somebody
personally handling a bunch of Excel
spreadsheets and there's no like quality
control to that I mean how do you how do
you confirm results with that model you
run it again you you do the work again
and what if the answer you get the
second time is different you do it again
and then it's like best two out of three
or like at what point do you stop and
say okay this was the right answer
I just I'm a huge fan
instill this in our analysts through
through training and any project we do
that we're going to document this thing
so that somebody else with the same
question and a different in a different
area can repurpose it next slide please
so a lot of our work has been focused on
turning some of the wishful thinking
ideas of our analysts into our code and
so something as simple as like the the
map in front of you if a there's nothing
complex going on under the hood here
you've got a few data sources coming in
representing events of a certain type in
certain places and I want to look at
them all together a good luck doing that
in a spreadsheet but it's not hard to
connect an analyst to the leaflet code
that does it to a little bit of deep
liar to bring stuff together to merge
stuff from the same source onto the same
location and put it all in a pop-up like
it's a real easy way to let somebody be
able to drill into events in a way that
was just unthinkable before so as we
introduce them to these ideas in
training or just in in sort of the
consulting model that we that we use
it's pretty interesting to see where
their mind goes and the questions that
though they'll be willing to start
asking so think about the next question
the next question would be you know
where have protests in whatever country
you're interested in where have they
occurred in the last two days like how
do you answer that well it's pretty easy
you go to Google or you go to your
favorite news site maybe you got some go
to sites for you know protests in the
last two days and Uganda calm and you
know and you'll get exactly what you
want until I say I don't really care
about the last two days anymore I want
to but want to know about the last two
months okay well maybe there's a protest
in Uganda in the last two months calm
and if there's not it gets a little
harder because those protests aren't in
the headlines anymore it gets terrible
if I say what about the last two years
or the last ten years the last 20 years
to find that stuff now you're gonna
start working with a database not a
problem because there's publicly
available databases that categorize
events and make them available to you
for free it's pretty easy stuff except
that the website that you go to to
interact with that data may not answer
all the questions you have
but to give you the data in this room
like that's the dream no problem give me
the data I'll take it from there outside
this room that's a nightmare because if
you didn't put it in my web interface
you know tool then I don't know what to
do so we're trying to bridge that gap
with our analysts I think you know the
analyst responds saying like you know if
I'm gonna use this data and I have to
build my own analysis and visualization
pipeline like that data's worthless well
how am I supposed to do that I don't
think it's necessary like you have to
build your own pipeline it's you get to
build your own pipeline like you get to
bring all that stuff in you get to do
whatever you want with it you get to
merge it with whatever other data
provider you know data you can get ahold
of you can do whatever analysis that
data will support I think that's a
really powerful you know paradigm shift
for for people to start thinking along
those lines instead of just just
accepting whatever you've whatever
you've been given okay next slide please
okay those are the closest I'll get to
tell you what we really do but so the at
some point we've got to share what share
the work we're we're doing right you can
do that in our markdown document you can
send it out as a HTML document if you
don't work for an organization that
strips all HTML documents from your
emails or maybe you want to host it as a
shiny app and shiny app is fantastic for
us because a lot of the questions our
analysts have that are geographically
focused easily transferable workflow to
another analyst another location with a
different country of interest you know I
bring up you know protests in Uganda and
you say well I care about Belarus well
there's a pretty good chance that
whatever workflow I use for Uganda you
could probably apply and that's one of
the big things that that we use shiny
for but the real reason I love shiny is
not so much just that capability it's
it's what it's what I appreciate about
it that maybe maybe is unique to me and
that is I've been in the army 14 years
so I'm not a full-stack developer I'm
not a front-end back-end whatever other
ends are required to build a nice
sophisticated production quality
cloud-based scalable app like I don't
know how to do that stuff but I can make
a pretty sweet shiny app if you know if
I know the question you want to ask and
you can connect me to the data we need
to use like that's a pretty powerful
thing I didn't learn that in the army
you know flying helicopters or teaching
statistics or anything else I've done
it's just it's not that hard to connect
an analyst to a really powerful
capability through the form of shiny so
if the right solution for for a problem
is to create an interactive app I think
we have a couple options the first is we
try to go by the closest thing on the
market the closest thing on the market
probably isn't exactly what we want is
probably really expensive so I liken
this to buying really overpriced shoes
that don't quite fit like okay maybe
they look good but they don't really do
they do what you want the other thing we
can do is if there's nothing on the
market we can basically solicit
vendors to excuse me to create something
that's exactly what we want well we're
gonna spend a year coming up with their
court requirements then we're gonna
solicit bids they're gonna run a pilot
study and then we're gonna you know
review contracts and by the time it's
all done it's not it's not probably
exactly what we want or maybe we don't
even have that problem anymore
so I liken this to ordering like custom
back ordered shoes for your kids
like by the time they get there the kids
feet don't they're not the right size
anymore it's a it's a terrible plan or
maybe I can just build it myself
excuse me if I build it myself the shoe
analogy kind of breaks down here because
I don't know anything about building
shoes but I take that back if you gave
me the materials and gave me the tools
and stackoverflow I could probably build
you some shoes they wouldn't be that
pretty but they might be effective just
like my shiny abs all right so to to go
back to my my leaf covered yard problem
only one of these solutions puts a
solution in the hands of the analysts
with any speed and that's what we do it
ourselves now this isn't necessarily the
solution for enterprise applications you
know to run our entire HR system maybe I
shouldn't build that in my office but
for a small ish problem that going
through these massive procurement
processes is just too painful
those problems just go unsolved unless
we give ourselves the tools to do it in
house with an analyst or two which is
actually really fun so I spend pretty
much all day with our studio open
because all the things I just told you
about are the tasks that I do to bring
value to the organization I'm autumn
ating things with scripts I'm creating
workflows the document common questions
and how we approach them in our markdown
I'm building shiny apps to to make a
tailorable question answerable to an
analyst anywhere they don't need to have
you know extreme data skills to be able
to use it
a little bit of training and we can we
can get them on their way all right so
I'll kind of tell you what's going on in
this slide then we're interested of
course in what's going on around the
world and instability in particular so I
made this a couple a couple of weeks ago
after as kind of a repurposed slide from
a presentation I gave a month ago when I
was highlighting this big dip in article
tone in the top right corner so the big
dip there happens to be corresponding to
win in Uganda the the president was
really being criticized for for
arresting and allegedly torturing one of
the members of their government who his
name is Bobby wine you might know him as
a Ugandan pop star he got pulled over as
a you know with weapons in the car at
least that was the charge he gets
arrested and so the whole world starts
piling on about how this is you know
abuse of power and and all that stuff
well it creates this huge in an article
volume related to the President of
Uganda everybody's getting upset about
it the whole world's calling for him to
you know behave better and such but it's
kind of short-lived within a couple of
weeks it it returns to normal maybe this
is something that an app could could
bring to an analyst attention but I'll
also point out this is the trouble with
with Newt you see this other big spike
on the right hand side and a lot of
positive tone about it that's when Kanye
West visited and gave him some shoes so
our interest was higher but short-lived
for the for the ladder okay and with
that since we're not taking questions I
won't just have to say that's classified
if you ask me a tough one and I am I am
complete thank you very much for your
time and Jared for the premium talking
spot
you